boxes of toys toiletries and kitchen
staples these packages are being sorted
scanned and sprayed with disinfectant
before being delivered to customers all
over Beijing the corona virus pandemic
has seen an increase in the use of
delivery services across China with more
customers choosing to shop from the
safety of their homes we have more to
deliver the in the past we're also
seeing an increase in deliveries of
staple food like a rice flour and the
oil medical supplies - like a face masks
and a cleaning products for weeks carbon
19 forced the closure of businesses
across China but delivery hubs like this
remained open throughout the crisis tens
of thousands of packages are purchased
at this distribution center every day
and most customers will receive their
items within 24 hours of ordering
companies have adapted to the outbreak
by limiting contact with clients smart
lockers are used to deposit parcels in
residential compounds analysts say the
widespread use of digital platforms has
enabled China to develop one of the most
sophisticated delivery networks in the
world China now has over 90 percent of
his towns covered by home delivery
service it's an industry of faster speed
intensive labor and a wide coverage
during lockdown millions of Chinese
residents relied on food delivery
drivers like these to survive though
infections have eased and restaurants
have reopened many customers still
prefer takeout home delivery is
convenient and essential I don't know
what I would eat if I didn't have home
delivery at the distribution center
delivery drivers have their temperatures
checked before starting daily rounds
face masks and vitamins are provided a
reminder of the risks they face well for
many buying online means shopping safely
for others it means putting their own
health on the line
Katrina you al-jazeera Beijing